THE ROLL [inaudible]
ALLEN [inaudible]
ARCHULETA [inaudible]
ATKINS [inaudible]
BATES [inaudible]
BELL [inaudible]
GORGEOUS [inaudible]
BRADFORD [inaudible]
CABALLERO [inaudible]
CHIANG [inaudible]
DODD [inaudible]
DORADO [inaudible]
GALGIANI [inaudible]
GLAZER [inaudible]
HERTZBERG [inaudible]
HILL [inaudible]
HUESO -- TITLE [inaudible]
JACKSON [inaudible]
JONES [inaudible]
LEYVA [inaudible]
MCGUIRE [inaudible]
MITCHELL [inaudible]
MONNING [inaudible]
MORE LOCK [inaudible]
THE REAL [inaudible]
NIELSEN [inaudible]
PAN [inaudible]
PORTANTINO [inaudible]
ROTH [inaudible]
RUBIO [inaudible]
STERN [inaudible]
STONE [inaudible]
NUMBER [inaudible]
WHY CASKEY [inaudible]
WIENER [inaudible]
WILK.
A QUORUM IS PRESENT WITH THE
MEMBERS AND OUR GUEST BEYOND THE
RAIL IN THE GALLERY PLEASE RISE
WILL BE LET IN PRAYER THIS
AFTERNOON BUYER CHAPLAIN.
SISTER MICHELLE GORMAN AFTER
WHICH PLEASE REMAIN STANDING
WILL BE LED IN THE PLEDGE OF
ALLEGIANCE TO THE FLAG BY
SENATOR BATES.
LET US CENTER OURSELVES IN GOD'S
PRESENCE.
I JUST DID A QUICK LITTLE SWITCH
HERE.
I KNOW THAT YOU PROBABLY KNOW
THAT THE BISHOP QUINN JUST HAD
HIS OF FUNERAL.
OVER AT THE CATHEDRAL
[inaudible]
AND HE WAS A GUEST CHAPLAIN HERE
ONE TIME AND IF WE FOUND HIS
LITTLE PRAYER THAT HE USED AND
I'D LIKE.
TO USE THAT IN MEMORY OF HIM.
IT WAS VERY -- MISTER QUINN LIKE
AT THE TIME.
EXCUSE MY ALLERGIES.
TO SO -- LET US CENTER OURSELVES
IN GOD'S PRESENCE.
HE SAYS DEAR DIVINE PARENTS IN
HEAVEN.
I PROPOSE A NEW BEATITUDES FOR
STATE SENATORS AND FOR ALL OF US.
THE FIRST BEATITUDE.
BLESSED ARE THE POOR IN SPIRIT.
THEIRS IS THE KINGDOM OF HEAVEN.
BLESSED ARE YOU WHO INSISTS.
THAT THE STATE'S LIVE WITHIN ITS
MEANS.
YOU WILL HAVE A BUDGET COMPLETED
BY JUNE FIFTEENTH.
LESTER YOU CUT THE FAT OUT OF
THE BUDGET.
BUT NOT THE LEAN SINEW AND BONE
OF THE POOR.
BLESSED ARE YOU WHO ARE JUST
DISCIPLINES BY YOUR PARTY. FOR
FOLLOWING YOUR CONVICTIONS
RATHER THAN PARTY LINES.
YOU WILL OVERCOME.
BLESSED ARE YOU WHO MORE IN NO.
BECAUSE YOU'RE CRITICIZED BY THE
POWERFUL LOBBIES.
YOU WILL BE COMFORTED BY YOUR
CONSCIENCE.
BLESSED.
ARE YOU WHO HUNGER AND THIRST
FOR THE SAKE OF THE POWERLESS.
THOSE NOT LIKELY TO GO TO THE
POLLS ON ELECTION DAY. FOR YOU
WILL HAVE SELF ESTEEM.
LESTER YOU WHO LIVE SIMPLY.
SO THAT OTHERS MAY SIMPLY LIVE.
AND THE EIGHTH BEATITUDES.
LESTER YOU VOTES ACCORDING TO
CONSCIENCE YOU CAN BE REELECTED.
LORD YOU KNOW THAT HISTORY WILL
NOT JUDGE THESE ELECTED LEADERS
BY THE NUMBER OF TERMS THEY
SERVED.
BUT BY THE QUALITY OF THOSE
TERMS.
AT THE END OF THEIR CAREERS MAY
THEY BE KNOWN NOT SIMPLY AS
POLITICIANS OR EVEN A SENATORS.
BUT AS STATES WHO STATES MEN AND
STATES WOMEN.
MAY BISHOP QUINN REST IN PEACE
AMEN.
I PLEDGE ALLEGIANCE TO THE FLAG.
OF THE UNITED STATES OF AMERICA
AND TO THE REPUBLIC FOR WHICH IT
STANDS. ONE NATION UNDER GOD.
INDIVISIBLE WITH LIBERTY AND
JUSTICE FOR ALL [inaudible]
THANK YOU.
OF COURSE THANK YOU SISTER
MICHELLE MEMBERS WE ARE GOING TO
MOVE TO PRIVILEGES OF THE FLOOR
TODAY WOULD BE AN EXCELLENT DAY
FOR BREVITY AS THERE IS A LOT
GOING ON ONCE WE'RE DONE WITH
SESSION.
LIKE TO START WITH SENATOR
DORADO.
SENATOR DORADO AT THE PRO TEM'S
DESK.
TODAY WE HONOR.
TODAY WE HONOR SAYS THAT CHAVEZ
BUT WE WELCOME THAT IS SEVERAL
METAL THE FIRST WOMAN PRESIDENT
OF THE UNITED FARM WORKERS.
JUST LIKE SAYS SON.
THAT IS A DOZEN SEE HER ROLE AS
A PERSONAL ACHIEVEMENT.
HE IS IN SACRAMENTO FOR THE SAME
REASONS THAT THE LETTERS WEREN'T
THAT CAME TO THIS BUILDING.
BACK THEN FARMWORKERS ARE BEING
POISONED IN THE FEELS
[inaudible]
TODAY.
THEIR CHILDREN'S BRAINS ARE
BEING DAMAGED BY NEW CHEMICALS.
BACK THEN FARMWORKERS LIVE THE
LABOR CAMPS LIKE I DID.
TODAY THE LAW STILL CONSIDERS
TENSE AND BUNK HOUSES LEGITIMATE
FARM WORKER HOUSING.
THIS SITE ISN'T INTERESTED IN
COMING HERE TO BE APPLAUDED.
SHE IS INTERESTED IN LEAVING
HERE WITH CHANGES ON THOSE
ISSUES THIS YEAR.
AS I HAVE HAD THE PLEASURE OF
GETTING TO KNOW MANY OF YOU MY
NEW COLLEAGUES.
I HAVE LEARNED YOU CAME FOR THE
SAME REASON AS THAT ISSA.
SO PLEASE JOIN ME IN WELCOMING
THIS WOMAN.
BRAVE ENOUGH TO KERRY ONE OF THE
GREATEST BURDENS FOR ANY LATINO.
TO CARRY ON AND THE BODY THE
LEGACIES OF SAYS OUR JOB IS AND
THE LOTUS WORD.
PRESIDENT ROH METAL.
PLEASE COME OFTEN.
PLEASE CONTINUE TO FIGHT HARD.
AND COUNT ON US IN THE STATE
SENATE.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH.
WELCOME TO THE CALIFORNIA STATE
SENATE.
WE LIKE TO BE ABLE TO WELCOME
ALL MEMBERS TO BE TO TAKE AN
OFFICIAL SENATE PHOTOGRAPHER --
PHOTOGRAPH.
IN THE BACK OF THE CHAMBERS
.
THANK YOU MEMBERS.
SENATORS WE NOW WOULD LIKE TO BE
ABLE TO TURN OUR ATTENTION
[inaudible]
TO SENATOR LEYVA.
FEDERAL AID AS A VERY SPECIAL
PRESENTATION TODAY WITH SOME
VERY IMPORTANT GAS GAS.
CENTER LEYVA THE FLOOR IS YOURS
THANK YOU MISTER PRESIDENT GOOD
AFTERNOON MEMBERS I RISE TODAY
TO INTRODUCE SEVERAL PEOPLE WHO
WORK HARD EVERY DAY TO IMPROVE
THE LIVES OF CALIFORNIANS.
DONATE LIFE CALIFORNIA IS
CHARGED WITH EDUCATING THE
PUBLIC ABOUT THE NEED AND
IMPORTANCE FOR PEOPLE TO
REGISTER THEIR DONATION WISHES
BEFORE TWO THOUSAND FOUR NO
REGISTRY HAD EXISTED FOR
CALIFORNIANS.
WHO WISH TO GIVE CONSENT TO BE
AN ORGAN AND I OR TISSUE DONOR
IN APRIL TWO THOUSAND FIVE
CALIFORNIA LAUNCHED AN ONLINE
ORGAN EYE AND TISSUE DONOR
REGISTRY CALL DONATE LIFE
CALIFORNIA?
ORGAN AND TISSUE DONOR REGISTRY
IN JULY TWO THOUSAND SIX THE
REGISTRY TOOK A GIANT STEP
FORWARD AS IT BEGAN ITS
PARTNERSHIP WITH THE DMV.
REPLACING DONOR STICKERS ON
DONOR CARDS.
THE REGISTER THE REGISTERED
ORGAN EYE AND TISSUE DONORS IN
CALIFORNIA HAVE SAVED NEARLY
THREE SEVEN THOUSAND LIVES AND
HELP HEAL AN ESTIMATED SIX
HUNDRED THOUSAND MORE PEOPLE
SINCE DONATE LIKE CALIFORNIA.
AND THE DMV BECAME OFFICIAL
PARTNERS TEN YEARS AGO.
WITH ME HERE TODAY ARE SEVERAL
LEADERS OF THIS REMARKABLE
ORGANIZATION WHEN I SAY YOUR
NAME GIVE US A LITTLE WAVE JIM
MARTIN CEO DONATE LIFE
CALIFORNIA.
DEANNA SANTANA THE PUBLIC
EDUCATION RELATIONS MANAGER OF
THE SIERRA DONOR SERVICES WE
ALSO HAVE WITH US TODAY JANICE
WHALEY THE NEW CEO OF DONOR
NETWORKS WEST.
SHAUN.
SLAVIC THE C. O. O. OF DONOR
NETWORK WEST AND KATHY CO BACK
THE DIRECTOR OF COMMUNICATIONS
FOR DONATE NETWORK WEST I'LL BE
HAVE THE CALIFORNIA STATE
LEGISLATURE AS WELL AS FAMILIES
ACROSS THE STATE WE THANK YOU
FOR THE WORK THAT YOU DO EVERY
DAY.
SENATORS LET'S GIVE A WARM
WELCOME TO OUR GUESTS TO THE
CALIFORNIA STATE SENATE.
I THANK THEM FOR THEIR HARD WORK.
WE WOULD NOW LIKE TO INVITE ALL
SENATORS FOR AN OFFICIAL SENATE
PHOTOGRAPH
.
THANK YOU CENTER LEYVA.
MEMBERS WE NOW WOULD LIKE TO BE
ABLE TO TURN OUR ATTENTION TO
SENATOR STERN.
WITH A VERY SPECIAL GAS.
THEATER STERN AT THE MAJORITY
LEADER'S DESK THE FLOOR IS YOURS
SIR GOOD FTERNOON.
FAMOUS PRESIDENT.
MEMBERS I I'M HERE TODAY TO
PRESENT TO YOU.
THE OUTGOING PRESIDENT
PEPPERDINE UNIVERSITY -- OUR
HOMETOWN GEM IN IN IN THE TOWN I
GREW UP IN AND HIS -- INCREDIBLE
WIFE DEBBIE.
ANDY IS SERVE THE THE UNIVERSITY
OF PEPPER DINE SINCE -- TWO
THOUSAND AND HE STARTED.
WHEN I WAS ACTUALLY TWO YEARS
OLD SO JUST TO GIVE YOU A SENSE
OF HIS TENURE -- HE'S BASICALLY
OVERSEEN -- THIS THIS INCREDIBLE
EPICENTER OF OF OF BIG THINKING
IN OUR BACKYARDS FOR FOR MANY
DECADES AND HE IS LAST YEAR WAS
THE HARDEST -- WE WENT THROUGH
THIS WILL THE FIRE AND
IMMEDIATELY BEFORE THAT A
BORDERLINE.
SHOOTING INCIDENT THAT TOOK ONE
OF HIS -- TRUE ANGELS ELENA
HOUSLEY AND SO ON HIS WAY OUT
WE'VE BEEN JUST SO BLESSED. TO
HAVE PRESENT IN BENTON AS A
STEADYING HAND IN A COMMUNITY
THAT.
STARTED STARTED TO TEAR ITSELF
APART AND DEALING WITH THESE
TRAGEDIES -- CHANGES PEOPLE AND
IT MAKES PEOPLE -- QUESTION EACH
OTHER AND I JUST WANT TO THANK
PRESIDENT BENTON.
AND DEBBIE FOR GIVING YOUR LIVES
TO THIS COMMUNITY. TWO
GENERATIONS OF STUDENTS BUT
MOSTLY THE STATE OF CALIFORNIA
HERE TODAY THAT'S WHY WERE
HONORING YOU.
YOUR LEADERSHIP -- AS AN
INSTITUTION THAT LIFTS YOUNG
PEOPLE UP THAT THAT BRIDGES GAPS
AND AND NOW IN THIS YEAR OF FIRE.
HOPEFULLY IS AN EPICENTER OF
KNOWLEDGE AND EXPERIENCE -- THAT
WE ALL TO OFTEN HAVE TO FACE
GOING FORWARD -- THANK YOU FOR
ALL OF YOUR DEDICATION FROM THE
BOTTOM OF OUR HEARTS AND I HOPE
YOU GET TO ENJOY YOUR RETIREMENT
WE'LL SEE IF THAT HAPPENS OR NOT
I HAVE A FEELING THAT PRESIDENT
BENDS NOT CAN BE VERY GOOD
RETIRING SO -- FOR MANY MANY
DECADES OF SERVICE THE
CALIFORNIA STATE SENATE THANK
YOU.
WELCOME TO THE CALIFORNIA STATE
SENATE
THANK YOU VERY MUCH
MEMBERS MESSAGES FROM THE
GOVERNOR WILL BE DEEMED READ
MESSAGES FROM THE ASSEMBLY WILL
BE DEEMED READ REPORTS OF
COMMITTEES WILL BE DEEMED READ
AND AMENDMENTS ADOPTED.
MOTIONS RESOLUTIONS AND NOTICES.
WE'RE NOW GOING TO MOVE TO
CONSIDERATION OF THE DAILY FILE
WE'RE GOING TO MOVE TO THE
SECOND READING FILE MISTER
SECRETARY PLEASE READ SENATE
BILL SIXTY SEVEN SENATE BILL SIX
SIXTY THREE WITH A MOMENT SINCE
IN A BILL FOR NINETY SEVEN WITH
A MINUTES.
THANK YOU MISTER SECRETARY THE
REMAINDER OF THE DAILY FILE WILL
BE REACHED.
DEFERRED IF THERE IS NO FURTHER
BUSINESS.
SEEING AND HEARING NONE SENATOR
WILK THE DESK IS CLEAR.
THANK YOU MADAM PRESIDENT THE
SENATE WILL BE IN RECESS UNTIL
THREE THIRTY PM AT WHICH TIME
THE GERMAN MOTION WILL BE MADE.
WE WILL RECONVENE RIGHT HERE ON
THURSDAY AT NINE AM.
THANK YOU SENATOR WELL WILL
THANK YOU MEMBERS HAVE A
WONDERFUL DAY THE SENATE WILL BE
IN RECESS UNTIL THREE THIRTY PM
AT WHICH TIME THE JOINT MOTION
WILL BE MADE WE WILL.
RECONVENE AT NINE AM ON THURSDAY
MORNING